Jeff D'Andria: Hey, everyone. Can everyone hear me okay?
Jeff D'Andria: Great, so yeah, we're… let's do this. All about resumes today.
Jeff D'Andria: So…
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, this is… just want to start off with this, so I think this is such a critical
Jeff D'Andria: Thing in getting interviews, getting a job offer.
Jeff D'Andria: At the end of the day, you really have one shot at a first impression,
Jeff D'Andria: what's gonna be presented today, and then it's gonna be a workshop. We're gonna get hands-on, you're gonna get your hands dirty and leave with a few things you can hold, and you're gonna make them today, workshop.
Jeff D'Andria: So, but this is all coming, right, from…
Jeff D'Andria: what I saw happening, right, at Microsoft, on their university recruiting team, at TikTok, and then really putting that to work, right, at places like…
Jeff D'Andria: Stanford with their CS students, at two boot camps, and now the community colleges, helping people tinker when they're not getting interviews, to crossing into, okay, I'm getting traction. I'm not getting interviews, I got an offer. Like, I'm good.
Jeff D'Andria: And so, if you're out there, and you're in a place where, you're not getting a ton of hits yet, it's all gonna come down to making adjustments, and…
Jeff D'Andria: today, by the end of it, you'll leave with a few adjustments that you can literally fire on to your resume and get out in the wild. So, looking forward to doing that with you today.
Jeff D'Andria: we actually… Nancy, Nicholas, and myself, and Satya, Professor Satya, we just met, actually. So, on top of the experience that I just shared, like, less than an hour ago, we just met with, ASHBE, which is one of the biggest applicant tracking systems. It's a tool that…
Jeff D'Andria: Thousands of employers use, to… to field resumes when someone applies to a job, and so we just spoke with a product manager from there about less than an hour ago, than an hour ago, about what's… what is… what are they seeing across the
Jeff D'Andria: all of their employers, and so many takeaways. So, actually, the last hour, I've been, like, updating, what we're about to cover today to accommodate what we just learned as well. So, really recent stuff.
Jeff D'Andria: So today,
Jeff D'Andria: you know, I'd say the segments will go in, and again, some of this is a little fluid, I just updated it after that talk. But I want to start with, like.
Jeff D'Andria: as much as I can, giving you a little sense of what the recruiter… like, what matters to them? You know, what is… what's the pain they're feeling, what… and really, like, what's the process they use in… in making an assessment?
Jeff D'Andria: whether someone's a yes or a no to get an interview. And then after that, let's… let's… let's, spice it up and…
Jeff D'Andria: Have someone, volunteer, and if no volunteer, we'll just pick somebody, to get their resume on the screen,
Jeff D'Andria: Also, like, please bring a job description or an internship position description. Would love to see how you're looking at that, and then you aligned your resume to match up, and let's just go under the hood, and everyone
Jeff D'Andria: We can do the process together a little bit, in a live hot seat, style.
Jeff D'Andria: And then after that, we'll do the hands-on piece of… I want to give you a couple things that you can literally try and should… if you're not getting hits, it's all about adjustments. So here's a couple things that you'll be able to craft, in our time today together.
Jeff D'Andria: to try something else, right? It's kind of like a target, like a dartboard. Like, I want to miss differently. If I'm missing up to the left, I want to miss way down to the right. And eventually, we'll slowly get to the bullseye, but we can't keep missing the same way.
Jeff D'Andria: So, it's okay if we don't know what's gonna stick, but we gotta do something different, okay?
Jeff D'Andria: So glad to do that with you today.